hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be
explaining the most recent events
in the boku no hero manga including
deku's insane
new quirk power horikoshi has absolutely
zero chill right now and things are
moving very quickly
so let's talk about it if you enjoyed
the boku no hero videos on our channel
and you want to see more
just leave a like and comment it only
takes a second but it helps a lot
and if you're new to anime out pro or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications before we get into it
a quick thank you to this video sponsor
raid
shadow legends raid shadow legends has
millions of players and dozens of tough
bosses
but it is best known for its epic
champions and now we've got big news
they've just introduced an entirely new
shadowkin
faction as you can see the shadowkin are
heavily inspired by the mythos of
medieval japan
and they've got nimble ninjas sharp
samurai
ominous oni and more personally i love
the designs for jintoro
sachi and life taker they look so cool
and i can't wait
to use them in battle check it out for
yourself just click the link
in the description to download raid for
free on mobile or
pc raid is always getting updated and
this month they've got
11 amazing new champions and 200 brand
new missions to complete
with an exclusive legendary champion as
your reward
if you finish them all they're also
adding five tough new levels to
almost every dungeon in the game that is
a crazy amount of content
to add in just one month raid keeps
growing in cool new ways
every single month and it's never been
easier to get started just click the top
link
in the description to try it out for
free on mobile
or pc finally this video will contain
boku no hero manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have
been warned we start things off with
confirmation that
no all might did not die off screen back
in chapter 3
11. i mean we all knew this even if all
might were to one day
die in the series it definitely wouldn't
be off screen
but it's still good to see and confirm
that he's okay
apparently allmight calls his batmobile
style
car hercules and it was only because
hercules has special defensive
properties that all might manage to
survive that explosion
not gonna lie naming your car hercules
is
kinda badass i dig it it turns out that
two villain assassins
are in pursuit of all might and they
seem to be intent
on taking his life so these are not
random villains who just happen to be
there
at that particular time these seem to be
villains who are on a mission to take
down all might
a mission that was most likely set up by
all for one himself
the goal of the assassins is to separate
all might and the other heroes from deku
so that lady nagant can capture deku and
take him to
all for one the presence of these
assassins and their seemingly
premeditated attack
suggests that all for one has put a lot
of time and planning
into this mission to capture deku so
the heroes might be in for a very
difficult fight in the next few
chapters almight is then forced to
abandon his car
right before the two villains destroyed
by lobbing rockets right through the
windshield
no hercules you were already best boy
in this entire arc anyway when the two
villains see all might in person
they are shocked by just how much he has
changed
he looks so weak and frail compared to
what he once was
and the villains agreed that all might
they once knew is long gone
and this is true almighty used to be the
symbol of peace
and he was easily the most famous hero
in all of japan
literally everyone knew what he looked
like and everyone knew him as this
buff and extremely powerful guy the
popular image of all might in his prime
is a far cry from all might after his
retirement
but just as the villains begin to think
that this version of all might will be
easy to handle
all might suddenly becomes fierce again
he is still in his emaciated small might
form
but he is determined to protect deku at
all cost
as he puts it that boy has been through
enough
and if anything were to happen to deku
it would happen over all might's dead
body
again i have to point out the strong
fatherly energy that all might is giving
off
in relation to deku just like a father
would do anything for his son
up to and including sacrificing his own
life to protect him
so too all might seems fully prepared to
die before letting
anything happen to deku this is pretty
heartwarming especially since deku's
biological father seems to have just
gone out to the store to buy some
beyblades and never came back
we then jump back to deku who is in the
process of zigzagging from building to
building
in the hopes of escaping lady nagan's
line of fire but even though deku
thought that his zigzagging movements
were going to keep him safe
he is suddenly struck by one of lady
nagan's bullets
the bullet instantly stops his progress
and sends him flying to the ground
at first deku doesn't understand how
lady nagant was able to hit him from her
position
and he thinks that maybe another villain
is helping her but eventually deku
realizes that
no it's not a second villain before he
send her
on this mission to capture deku all for
one transferred a flying quirk
over to lady nagant and so she is now
using
airwok to soar through the air and
target deku from
up above deku knows that if lady nagan
can get close
enough she will be able to shoot him at
point-blank range and he will not be
able to avoid it
he will then become immobilized and
she'll be able to capture him and take
him to all for one
so he has to change up his strategy and
he has to do it now
as he lands on the ground deku unleashes
smoke screen
at full throttle until the entire street
he was on
is covered in smoke as soon as she sees
the smoke
lady nagant realizes that deku also has
multiple quirks and so at least for the
time being
lady nagant is unable to locate deku she
has the perfect vantage point from her
position
up in the air but because of all the
smoke she can't locate her target
so she can't take him down however the
vestige of n
the original user of smokescreen
suddenly appears and warns deku that
releasing too much smoke at once
is a risky strategy the smoke won't last
forever
and as soon as it clears deku will have
nowhere to run
but here's the thing deku never intended
to run
he just needs to buy some time so that
he can unlock
a new quirk the quirk once used by the
third
one for all user but the third user
himself doesn't necessarily
love this idea he says that deku still
hasn't tried
using this quirk which means that deku
has zero experience with it
and so he has no idea whether he can
even handle this new power
but of course we all know deku and we
know that he will never pass up on an
opportunity to sacrifice his own body
and risk his own life
in the name of heroics deku believes
that he simply can't afford to take his
time
learning to use this new quirk he has to
do whatever it takes to stop lady nagant
right now and after he takes care of her
he has to stop
all for one and she got a key time is
running out
so instead of mastering the third user's
quirk gradually deku is going to force
himself to learn to use this crazy new
power
on the fly in true shonen protagonist
style
he is going to improvise suddenly
deku begins emitting vast amounts of
energy from his body
and in the unofficial translation the
brand new quirk that he is using
is called fojin which in chinese martial
arts
refers to an explosive release of
internal power
so we're not talking about actual
explosives here like with bakugo
we're talking about an explosive burst
of energy that can be released when the
user makes certain physical movements
with his body
this burst of energy will presumably
take those movements to an entirely
different
level of power meanwhile lady nagant is
still floating above all the smoke
and she is using a rifle scope that she
herself has created with her quirk to
observe the streets below
the scope looks like this creepy
extension of her own flesh
like something you would see in an alien
movie but it's
also kind of cool at the same time and
let's be real
no matter how creepy her quirk is lady
nagant
is still waifu deku then uses parts of
his outfit
including gran torino's cape his own
mask and his backpack
in order to create decoys that will draw
lady nagan's attention
as soon as she sees these articles of
clothing moving above the smoke
lady nagant shoots them but she quickly
realizes that she didn't hit
her target deku then takes advantage of
these brief distractions to get the drop
on lady nagant he suddenly bursts
through the roof of the building above
which she was flying
and he grabs the villain waifu by the
arm deku must have used the third user's
quirk
fajin to launch himself up through the
building
and into the sky with incredible speed
and that is how this chapter ends
deku seems to have finally taken the
upper hand
in this fight although the fight is
likely far from over
and the new quirk the third user's quirk
looks absolutely
nuts a lot of people speculated that the
third user's quirk could be a speed
quirk
and even though it technically isn't
super speed the fact that deku was able
to shoot up from the ground
blast through a building and launch
himself at lady nagant so quickly
demonstrates that speed is indeed a
major element of this
quirk the quirk seems to allow deku to
both power up
and speed up all of his movements at
least for a moment
which could prove to be extremely useful
in battle especially if combined with
his other attacks like say detroit smash
but even though this new quirk seems to
be pretty overpowered
because it seems to draw on the user's
inner power
it is likely that there are significant
drawbacks to overusing this quirk
it probably has limitations like you can
only use it a certain number of times
and or you can only use it for a few
seconds at a time
and it may also take a significant toll
on the user's body
if deku ends up using too much of his
inner power by
overusing this quirk he may end up
hurting himself
or tiring himself out even more quickly
than if he was using normal physical
attacks
i can definitely see this being a really
powerful and useful quirk
but a quirk with serious drawbacks and
limitations
what do you guys think do you like
deku's latest quirk
and what else do you think that this
quirk can do it has only just been
introduced so i'm sure we're gonna learn
a lot more about it
and see very cool new powers sometime
soon
also what limitations and drawbacks do
you think there will be
for using this quirk finally now that we
have a good idea of what the third
user's quirk is
what do you think the final quirk the
second user's quirk
is going to be since they're saving it
for last i feel like it's going to be
absolutely
incredible but let me know what you guys
think down below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more boku no hero content
right here on the channel please leave
that like to let me know it only takes a
second but it helps a lot
and if you're new to anime out pro or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter and
instagram at anime uproar thanks again
to this video sponsor
raid shadow legends check them out for
free
link in the description as always thank
you guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you